c'est jour de rentrée dans cette école
primaire de shawinigan après des
semaines à la maison les élèves sont de
retour à l'école l'école qui vont
retrouver aujourd'hui c'est pas la même
école qui qui ont quitté en mars fait
que c'est ce qu'on voit c'est ce qu'on
va savoir dans les prochains jours comme
ça qu'ils vont vivre une expérience
comme certains parents ce chauffeur
d'autobus et inquiets dans l'ensemble du
québec environ 55 % des enfants sont de
retour à l'école
à l'école primaire immaculée conception
de shawinigan seulement 60 des 230
élèves sont présents
ce que les parents ont pu penser qu'à
cause de la quantité d'élèves qu'on
avait voulu voir comment ça allait se
passer avant de retourner leurs enfants
interdits pour nous de rentrer dans
l'école seule solution demandé au
directeur de filmer ce qu'il a fait en
gamme une bonne distance
ici plus rien n'est pareil partout on
rappelle l'importance de se laver les
mains de garder deux mètres de distance
enseignants des masques de protection
qu'ils peuvent porter alors faut pas
penser qu'ils vont se tenir à deux
mètres l'a bien mesurer toute la journée
on y va avec notre gros bon sens pour
éviter la propagation de la maladie il
n'y a que onze élèves par classes et les
élèves restent dans le même local toute
la journée si on ait besoin quelque
chose on lève la main on peut pas
vraiment on peut pas vraiment se
déplacer il ya des règles et puis je
sais qu'ils sont bonnes options les suit
je pense pas qu'on envoie malade mais
avant j'avais un peu de crème
ici le personnel est prêt à intervenir
si jamais les mâles et 10 déclarent les
protocoles sont en place pour des jets
ses élèves la berre une salle
d'isolement
alors on peut déjà faire des premiers
soins et apprendre un peu l'état de
l'enfant et un communiqué ce moment-là
immédiatement aux parents pour qu'ils
viennent chercher leurs enfants dans la
cour d'école pas de ballons les modules
de jeux sont interdits que des carrés de
couleurs au sol pour rappeler aux
enfants la règle des 2 m ici dans la
région du personnel des écoles
secondaires a été appelé en renfort un
enseignant d'éducation physique exemple
aux seconds à peu venait compléter la
tâche on ne vous le seul du
même à faire un enseignant de français
de mathématiques donc vraiment l'eau si
tout le monde met l'épaule à la roue
cette école comme bien d'autres va
devenir un véritable laboratoire en
prévision de la grande rentrée du mois
de septembre
ici jean philippe robillard radio canada
shawinigan